did you know that the Demon King Mozan
was married five times in the past or
that tanjiro is one of only three people
confirmed to have seen the legendary
blue Spider Lily or that's two of the
hashira actually secretly loved each
other and ironically one half of that
secret relationship is the love hashira
of mitsuri kandoji but what's maybe even
more incredible is that she's actually
the only hachira who didn't have some
sort of horribly traumatic childhoods
and that's because she grew up in a
basically normal family with five kids
where her biggest problem was that her
ridiculous physical strength kept
scaring away potential husbands and
besides her strengths her pink hair was
also a real issue with the guys but I
think it's kind of cool actually because
she's the only anime girl that I know of
that has an actual reason for her wacky
hair color and that's because we're
being told that hers actually only
turned this bright shade of pink because
she ate way way too much Sakura Mochi
and so all of this led to mizuri being
pretty depressed at some point however
she decided she didn't want to fake who
she was to find a husband spend and so
she joined the Demon Slayer core after
the leader told her that she should
embrace her true abilities which is when
the real drama starts because she
secretly fell in love with one of the
other hashira who we'll talk about in
just a second but first we're continuing
with the anime characters the upper Moon
six demons [__] and gutaro who are not
nearly as fortunate growing up as
mitsuri that's because these two were
actually born to a prostitute mother and
she was such a terrible Mom that she
actually tried to kill both of her kids
their mom particularly was jealous of
[__] and even tried to cut off her
beautiful hair but yutaru went on a
rampage to save his sister however
yutaro himself was not quite as
fortunate in the looks department and he
was consistently mocked for his
appearance voice and his poor hygiene
which I mean come on wouldn't have bad
teeth if they were forced to eat bugs
and rats to survive poor guy and gutaro
couldn't always protect daki though
because years later when she was a
successful oiron she actually stabbed a
samurai from mocking her brother this
made the samurai then Furious and he
tied her up and literally burned her
alive yutaro barely managed to save her
and he killed a samurai in Revenge and
if that wasn't bad enough yet no one
would even help the siblings until the
upper rank demon Doma found them and
turned them into demons as well and
that's how the pair came to then
terrorize the Entertainment District for
centuries however there is another super
powerful early Story character who I bet
you didn't know was mocked for his looks
as well and that is sankoji urokodaki
the former water hashirao who first
trained tanjiro and the current
waterhashiragu among his many other
Feats urokodaki is famous for capturing
and imprisoning the Hand demon that was
the main enemy during tanjiro's test to
become a demon slave but despite being
crazy strong he apparently has a quite
soft side as well because demons used to
make fun of his gentle features and this
bothered him so much that he started
wearing this fox mask to hide his face
and of course you might recognize these
masks because they were also worn by
these spirits makomo and sabito now
these two were orphans who were trained
by urokodaki and makomo lived some time
before sabito and when she went for her
final selection test she was killed by
the hand demon and yes the same is true
for sabito who was also killed by this
ugly monstrosity though apparently
sabito took the test at the same time as
you and he actually saved you during
their week on the mountain however
because of their failures both of these
two became spirits who then lived on the
mountain where they helped tanjiro train
as well and as I just mentioned their
killer was this disgusting looking
figure who was captured and imprisoned
by urokodaki but we also know that the
very first person that this demon killed
was actually his older brother after he
was first turned into a demon which
admittedly is nowhere near as insane as
the drum Demon's backstory though
because this demon used to be a member
of the 12 upper moons which are the 12
strongest demon in the world however he
somehow lost his ability to grow
stronger from eating humans so the Demon
King muzam took away his position and
ever since then the drum demon has been
obsessed with growing stronger to regain
his position and actually another
character who lost something very
important to him is this guy actually
you know what wait pretty much every
character in the story has lost someone
or something very important to them
anyways
who is the father of the flame hashira
from the mugan Trainor he was married to
Ruka and also had another son named
shinjiro now shinjiro used to be the
former flame hashira and even saved it
this guy from his super tragic past and
which will we be discussing in just a
moment but shinjiro became a deadbeat
dad after his wife died in fact he was
so torn up about his wife's death that
when he encountered a lower ranked demon
he took out his anger by cutting it up
over and over again but never actually
killing the monster which is really
messed up now even though demons are
mostly all awful monsters that doesn't
mean that they can't have some serious
trauma and tragic backstories of their
own which is perfectly shown actually by
the lower Moon 5 demon adui who was
actually born to a pretty normal family
with parents who actually loved him he
was a pretty weak child though so when
muzan offered to make him a strong demon
he immediately accepted the offer but
after killing a household servant rui's
parents tried to kill him because they
didn't want him to become a monster
whoops uh too late for that I guess so
Louie actually killed his beloved
parents and then spent the next 20 years
unsuccessfully trying to recreate that
special family Vibe with demons that he
transformed into fellow spiders and uh
if you think that that is already
Twisted then just wait until you hear
about enmu's disturbing past that's
because when he was human he could
actually not tell the difference from
dreams or reality which sounds
interesting but as an adult this led to
him to pretend to be a doctor and he
could tell patients that they were
healed even though they were about to
die which is a pretty messed up thing to
do but that's not even the worst part
here because one day The Demon King was
literally in the middle of eating enmu
but instead of being terrified he
actually praised muzan which somehow
then convinced him to turn enmu into a
demon ah okay wow I never actually
realized how messed up some of the
backstories in Demon Slayer actually are
until making this video in fact the
standard backstory for a character is
basically just family killed by demons
which is true for these little three
helpers from the butterfly Mansion as
well whose names are Sumi Kyo and naho
and the same can be said for our here
however she has a bit more to a
backstory because at one point she was
actually able to pass the test to become
a Demon Slayer although she claims it
was just pure luck and actually each of
these characters were taken in by the
flower hashirashi Nobu kocho whose
parents were you guessed it also killed
by demons but she and her sister were
actually saved by the stone hashira who
has literally one of the most heroic
backstories in the manga which we'll
discuss in just a second but one other
fact about shinobu that you might not
know is that her uniform was actually
supposed to be incredibly revealing just
like mitsuri's however she immediately
burned turn the open chest jacket and
requested a fully buttoned one and
another mind-blowing fact about shinobos
past is that she became the head of the
butterfly Mansion at just 14 years old
which again is kind of wild I mean kids
in the Demon Slayer World basically seem
to become like adults once they hit 10 I
guess but she Nobu only got this role
because her older sister Kanaya died in
battle against the upper ranked demon
Doma and before she died Kanai and
shinobu both rescued this girl from her
terrible childhood as well however
shockingly it turns out that being a
slave wasn't even the worst part of
kanaw tsuyuni's backstory and that's
because she grew up with parents who
were so abusive that she literally had a
mental breakdown and repressed all of
her emotions her parents then sold her
into slavery where she was rescued by
the culture sisters they took her to the
butterfly mansion and she eventually
learned flower breathing from just
watching shinobu and Kanai in fact this
made her so strong that she took the
final selection test without her
adoptive sister permission and while
kano's traumatic past might break your
heart just as it did mine no one should
cry over this sickening liar right here
because this is the upper rank for demon
huntengu who was such a frantic liar
during his human life that he would
commit horrible crimes and then cry and
scream that he was innocent his mind was
actually so Twisted that he was married
multiple times but would always end up
killing his own family however he was
eventually caught and sentenced to death
only to be turned into a demon by muzan
who does seem to have a great judgment
for character already in this video and
while all of this is pretty messed up
his partner in the attack on the
swordsmith village is even more
disturbing and that's because as a child
yoko's parents drowned while out fishing
at Sea and eventually he saw their
bodies washed up on shore and developed
a sickening fascination with corpses and
in particular dead fish this led to his
village believing that he had gone
insane Lane which I mean fair enough and
eventually gyoko killed another kid who
was making fun of him however the
murdered kid's parents got their Revenge
by stabbing Yoko but unfortunately for
the rest of the world he somehow managed
to survive until he was turned into a
demon by once again muzan good job muzan
which of course meant that he could
continue making his creepy body art
until he was finally defeated by the
missed hashira muchirotokito but like
pretty much all the hashira his
childhood was awfully tragic once again
muichiro and his twin brother were born
into a wood-cutting family but his mom
died from illness and his father fell
off a cliff well I guess that's a new
way to die in the story now their
parents deaths left the twins to survive
on their own however the leader of the
demon Slayers actually tried to recruit
the boys many times but muchiro's
Brothers always turned them down so they
continued alive until a demon came and
attacked them leaving muchiro's brother
dead and so as a result the hashira
managed to kill the demon but seeing his
brother die literally broke his mind and
he lost all of his memories and
personality luckily he was then found by
the demon Slayers and after recovering
he became a hashira in the insanely
short time of two months which may sound
crazy but it is actually making a lot of
sense considering that he has a super
strong relative from the past we will
talk about by the end of this video
though muchiro is not the only
descendant of a super overpowered
bloodline and that's because this flashy
hashira right here came from a legendary
clan of Shinobi but as cool as that
sounds tengen's childhood was pretty
awful once again by the age of 15 he's
basically forced into getting married
which I guess isn't all that bad when
these three are your wives but the worst
part is that he and his eight siblings
were forced to face each other in death
matches until only the two strongest
survived which again
however when tengen then learned that he
was actually killing his brothers and
sisters he left the clan once and for
all and never returned and while he was
sometimes thinking about wiping out his
terrible family altogether he could
never bring himself to actually kill his
dad and only remaining brother which I
guess is Honorable in its own way but
it's not the only broken brotherly bond
in the story because genya and his
brother sonemi have actually never
gotten along after their tragic
childhoods they're once again abusive
father was randomly stabbed by someone
in the village and their mom worked
tirelessly to provide for the entire
family that is of course until she was
turned into a demon and attacked her own
family and all the kids were killed
except genya and his older brother who
somehow managed to kill their demon mom
however young panicked and shouted
atsanimi for killing their mom and the
two have never gotten along since and
later both boys joined the Demon Slayer
core where genya learned that she cannot
use breathing techniques but he does
actually have the super rare ability to
consume demon flesh and gain some
demonic strength and healing and of
course genia's heroics during the
swordsmith village Arc helped save
everyone's favorite swordsmith Hagen
zuka apparently his massive temper
tantrums have always been an issue ever
since he was a kid and he even caused
his parents to have mental breakdowns
which resulted in haganzuka being raised
by The Village Chief instead which
honestly based on how many orphans there
actually are in the story apparently it
is a really good thing that they also
are equally as many old men willing to
take these kids inapprently because even
zenitu was not raised by his parents in
fact when he was on his own as a kid he
gave all his money to some random Crush
who then stole it and ran away with
another guy poor dude lost it all for
love but this left zenitsu in a terrible
debt until this old man jigorol took him
in and trained him as a swordsman
however zenitu was so scared of training
that one day he climbed a tree and was
then struck by lightning which
permanently changed his hair to its now
now very popular yellow and while this
made gigoro Furious he still cared for
zanitsu like a son and this is a pretty
cool trainer to have I'd say since he
was a former thanda hashira who only
retired when he lost his leg during a
battle when he was like 35 years old on
the other hand one character who isn't
as cool is the timari demon from season
1 susamaru who apparently loved to play
with these handballs even as a human
then we have murata who was one of the
only survivors of the spider demon
attack on Mount natagumo though
apparently before becoming a Demon
Slayer a girl he liked complimented his
hair which is why he regularly Grooms
and applies camellia oil to keep it
silky smooth is to know I guess that
someone at least in this dangerous wild
world of demons Lair actually takes care
of themselves and next up is the man who
saved tanjiro zenitsu and inosuke after
the Entertainment District Arc which is
goto a member of the cleanup Brigade but
did you know that he actually was worthy
of becoming a Demon Slayer himself
however he did choose in the end to be
one of the helpers instead I wonder why
that was just like I'm also wondering
why you're not subscribed to the channel
but you can do it right now so go ahead
and click that button for even more
amazing anime content but for one of the
characters you would never expect to
play an important role next this is
yushiro who was once a sick boy under
care of the gentle demon Tamayo and with
yushiro about to die Tamayo asked if he
wanted to become a kind demon just like
herself so that he could live he agreed
and as a result he's been at her side
ever since however he actually loves
Tamayo deeply which may sound childish
but their bond actually plays a huge
role at the end of the story now at this
point you might be wondering where our
main character is but don't worry
because we will be getting to him very
soon but first did you know that
tanjiro's mother Kia kamado actually
knows where to find the legendary blue
spider lily flowers that's because we
learned in the special fan book number
two that she knew where to find the
special flower and we even see that
tanjiro had a flashback to the flower
during his fight with rui but that's not
all that we know about Kia because
apparently she once killed a wild boar
with her incredibly hard head so it does
seem like we finally know where tanjito
God's bad special ability from as well
but of course as you know it's not the
only special ability in the family
because tanjiro's father tanjuro was
able to use the legendary Sun breathing
which of course has been passed down
through their family lineage tanzuro was
also incredibly strong though he had no
connection with the Demon Slayer core
however there was one even more
legendary ability that we learned later
on in the story which he also passed
down to his son more on that in a second
but first we have tanjiro's siblings
Takeo hanako siguru and orokuto who were
all killed by muzan and of course we can
forget nizugo who helped the family by
going without new clothes and other
items to make sure that all of them had
food and in fact before the incident she
was most often helping her mother around
the house which does now bring us to
tanzuro and we've just discussed his
family and their humble upbringing but
there were a few other exciting events
throughout the early parts of his life
that we need to talk about like when he
for example got his famous car after
saving his brother from a hot cattle he
also learned the basics of sun Breathing
by watching his father perform the
traditional rituals but there is one
scene from later on the manga that also
showed us that his father could use the
overpowered ability transparent worlds
now this super rare ability lets you see
through someone's skin down to their
muscles and bones we know this because
in chapter 151 his sickly father easily
killed a massive bear his father then
told him that with enough practice his
mind would not need to think but he
could just be able to react to what he
was seeing unfortunately the father then
died from his illness just a few days
later and tanjiro then inherited the
hanafuda earrings and as sad as it is to
see tanjiro lose his father at least he
had a solid family for all almost his
entire life because the same can be said
for inosuke well at least not a human
family of course he did have parents but
his mother fled with baby nosga because
his father was horribly abusive once
again and they eventually came to this
Twisted culture who worshiped the upper
Moon two demon Doma but when his mother
realized that Doma was eating people
alive she then ran away once again
unfortunately Doma ended up chasing her
and she was forced to throw baby inosuke
into a river before dolma caught up and
ate her eventually inosuke was then
found by wild boars which is how he grew
up until he became a Demon Slayer but
you know actually turned out pretty well
for him but it all started once again
with another deadbeat husband and I'm
kind of starting to think that they are
almost as evil as all the demons in the
story I mean another example of this is
from the biwa Demon's backstory from
later on in the manga that's because
when she was a human she was a decent
biwa player who struggled to make much
money however her husband would then
gamble away even the little money that
they had and when he sold her only nice
kimono she got so Furious that she's
straight up killed him however that very
same night when she went on stage to
perform her musical performance was so
amazing that she actually continued to
commit murder every time that she had a
performance and this continued until she
tried to you know kill muzan but he then
at least turned her into a demon I guess
so again who is the real evil here
demons or awful husbands I mean muzan
technically is both which just goes to
show that good dads are super rare just
like tanjiro's great ancestor sumioshi
kamado now this man lived with his wife
suyako and their daughter sumire about
500 years before the current storyline
this family was actually attacked by
demons and luckily saved by the
legendary swordsman yoriti who we'll
discuss in full detail in just a moment
but this was a super important moment
for the story because sumayyoshi then
became friends with yorichi and
eventually the troubled swordsman told
ancestor his entire life story and of
course the most important part was that
Yori Ichi showed sumiyoshi's Sun
breathing which is how it got passed
down the family line all the way to
tanjuro but of course the original
sunbreather has also one of the most
intense and also complicated backstories
in the entire story now this is
yorichitsugi Kuni who lived around 500
years ago he is literally the strongest
Demon Slayer ever and was the one who
first created the breathing styles of
fighting yorichi grew up with his twin
brother michikatsu and when they were
growing up he was a very quiet kind
child who took care of his sick mother
however he literally did not speak at
all as a kid so his father was going to
send him to a temple and this is
actually how he first got the hanafuda
earrings because his mother gave them to
him because she hoped that they would
help him finally speak however everyone
lost their minds when they saw him do
this during sword practice while his
brothers struggled to even touch the
instructor yoriichi picked up the
Practice Sword for the very first time
he then instantly struck the teacher
four times and left him with massive
bumps and bruises which left everyone
mind blown but the excitement was very
short-lived because yorichi didn't like
the feeling of hitting someone so he did
not end up picking up a weapon again
while he lived at home nonetheless his
legendary strength meant that his father
instantly started to show him more
affection he then decided to send his
twin brother to the temple instead of
yorichi which a kind of mean move there
and this of course made his younger
brother incredibly jealous but yorichi's
super insane strength was not the only
thing that separated the two brothers
that's because yorichi was actually born
with the Demon Slayer Mark which
basically makes a person much stronger
and he could even naturally see the
transparent World which was how he knew
that his mother was sick when no one
else did and when their mother finally
died of her illness yorichi decided to
leave home so that his brother would not
be sent to the Temple after all then
after leaving he met his wife utta and
years later they were about to have a
baby but just like any happy thing in
any of these backstories so far a demon
came and messed things up really bad for
them and so while yorichi was going to
get a midwife to help his wife give
birth UTA was attacked and kills this
drove yorichi to intense sadness and he
even held his wife's body for 10 days
straight and after his time of grieving
he then became a Demon Slayer which of
course was a completely game-changing
moment and that's because of his natural
talents he taught the other Slayers
everything that he knew which included
adapting Sun breathing into new
breathing styles to suit each individual
person years later yorichi then
encountered muzan and Tamayo and while
the Demon King was a genuine threat the
legendary Demon Slayer instantly
defeated him and the demon only barely
managed to escape and then yorichi just
let Tamayo Go free but next we have the
probably dumbest moment in the entire
story and that's because soon after this
event several other demons layers
confronted yorichi and kicked him out of
the Demon Slayer core because his
brother had become a demon too which
we'll discuss more in just a moment
which is just absolutely crazy but is
the reason that he eventually went to
talk with Sumi Yoshi kamado about his
life so I guess it kind of ended up
working out in the end and now skipping
ahead 60 years into the future yorichi
encountered with his demon brother one
last time but actually died of old age
during the battle which literally drove
his brother mad with rage I mean how
would you feel if you spent your entire
life trying to beat your brother but
then when you finally have a chance he
dies of old age let me talk about
frustrating right but despite everything
his brother did yorichi still treasured
a small flute that his brother gave him
when they were kids and so let's now
back up a little bit and talk about
michikatsu biowich's brother because he
then goes on later to become the upper
Moon one kokusibo now I just explained
about their shared childhood and how
michikatsu went from being the favorite
Child to being the outcast but once
yorichi left michikatsu eventually
became the Lord of his family house he
did marry and have children but then one
day a demon kills his soldiers while
they were out in the woods luckily
michikatsu was saved by yorichi who was
a Demon Slayer at this point and it was
at that time that michikatsu decided to
leave everything behind and become a
Demon Slayer as well he very quickly
learned his own breathing style which of
course needed to be Moon breathing and
got his own Demon Slayer Mark as well
however getting this Mark was actually
the start of his downfall because every
Demon Slayer with the mark besides
yolichi died before their mid-20s and so
michikatsu became obsessed with survival
and this eventually led to his encounter
with muza and so because of his intense
desire to live michikatsu agreed to
become a demon and transformed into
kokoshibu and then after years of
killing humans including the leader of
the Demon Slayer core kokoshibo became
the Opera Moon one and together with
muzam they wiped out every single Demon
Slayer who used the sun breathing style
but fast forward 60 years and kokoshibo
only survived the battle with yorichi
because his brother died again of old H
this basically left him constantly angry
at his brother even though he ended up
taking his brother's treasured flute and
keeping it himself but that's actually
not the end of his fascinating backstory
because remember the wife and kids that
he left behind to become a Demon Slayer
well that Family actually were the past
relatives of the missed hashira muichiro
tokito that we mentioned earlier which I
guess explains exactly why muichiro was
so naturally talented because he was
related to kokoshibo and yorichi and
while muchiro eventually helps defeat
kokoshibo he certainly wasn't alone
sonomi the wind hashira also took part
in that battle and as we already
explained with genya he had the
unfortunate task of killing his mother
who had transformed into a demon in the
past but that actually isn't the end of
his sad story because after roaming
around killing demons on his own he was
then found by a demon Slayer named Masa
chica who brought sonemi to a Demon
Slayer trainer so that he could join the
core now these two basically became like
brothers but when they fought the lower
rank one demon and so this tragedy made
tsunami really Furious and he even
snapped at the leader of the Demon
Slayer core before reading his dead
friend's will which calmed him down a
little bit and another one of the
participants of this legendary battle is
the strongest current Demon Slayer the
stone hasidog yo Mei himejima and oh boy
he has also one of the wildest
backstories in the story his mother died
giving birth to him and his father died
of some sort of illness and to make
things worse a fever caused him to go
blind as a child very early on
eventually he was living in a temple
with a bunch of other orphan kids
however things went terribly wrong when
one of the kids let a demon write to
them the demon then killed most of the
kids even though gilme tried to save
them and in the end the only one who
survived was the youngest girl who's
just stayed behind gome while he was
punching the demon until the sun rose
however unfortunately this is not a
happy ending because that little girl
got confused and actually started
babbling that Gomez was a monster this
made people believe that yomey had
actually killed all the other kids and
he was sentenced to execution which is
where he was headed until he was saved
by the leader of the Demon Slayer Corps
who brought him in to become a Demon
Slayer and all of that happened because
of this slimy kid right here kaigaku was
living in the temple but was actually
stealing their money one night he was
caught by the other kids and forced out
but he then ran into a demon and then in
order to save his own life he led the
demon to the others which resulted in
the tragic bloodbath but that's not the
end of the story here because eventually
he was taken in by digoro the former
Thunder hashira and trained alongside
zinsu however only shortly after
becoming a Demon Slayer he then ran into
kokusibo and he chose to become a demon
instead of dying in other words truly he
is one of the worst people in the entire
story which actually is kind of crazy
that he became a Demon Slayer player in
the first place because usually
is really good at understanding people I
mean he basically recruited all of the
hashira by himself and he has even
earned all of their respect despite his
crippling illness and if you didn't know
that illness runs throughout his family
because of their blood relation to Musa
it's basically a sort of curse that
kills all the men before they turn 30
and the women have to remarry and change
their name or they will die as well even
kagaya's father killed himself when he
was just 19 years old because he
couldn't handle seeing so many demon
Slayers constantly dying as a result
this left kagaya in charge at the age of
only four years old which is just
absolutely stupid honestly and then when
he was 13 his wife amane was elected to
marry him again what's with the ages
here although he would only agree to
marry her if she actually wanted to
which obviously she did and she later
gave birth to the quintuplets hinaki
nitsika kiria quina and and oh boy five
kids at once
but one thing that kagaya can't do for
himself is fight which is exactly the
specialty of the upper Moon 3 akazah as
a kid his father was very sick and so
since they didn't have any money akasa
would go out and steal to pay for his
father's medicine however he ended up
being caught and his father then
committed suicide out of Shame which I
mean oh boy the fathers and then after
this akasa was banished and he was
eventually found by the leader of a dojo
after living at the dojo for a few years
akasa became an incredibly strong
fighter and was even going to marry the
leader's daughter however of course I
mean this is Demon Slayer we can't just
have a happy backstory so in this case a
jealous rival Dojo leader poisons their
drinking water the dojo leader and his
daughter drank the poisoned water and
died immediately which sent akazah into
a rage and he literally killed all 67
members of the other Dojo with his bare
hands I mean even as a human what an
absolute monster another called this
display caught of course the attention
of muzan who then turned akazah into a
demon which of course came during the
battle against tanzido and you and
speaking of the waterhashira he grew up
with his older sister but one day she
sacrificed herself to protect him from
you guessed it a demon and after this he
was sent away to a distant relative but
he ran away instead however this turned
out to almost be a very bad decision
because he got lost and nearly died on a
mountain the only reason he survived is
because he was rescued and trained by
urokodaki which sent him on a path to
become a Demon Slayer now we've already
talked about the equally tragic
backstories of the upper Moon one and
three but upper Moon 2 doma's childhood
was actually fairly okay in comparison
he was born with extraordinary good
looks and for some reason people
believed that he could communicate with
the gods as a result they kind of formed
this cult with him as the leader and
even though Doma never believed any of
this one day his mother killed his
father because he was cheating on him
and then she committed suicides now
don't
care about any of this
for 20 years old she's then turned into
a demon by muzan he still kept the cult
going though but now he would eat the
followers whenever he was hungry and
yeah I mean weird but I guess different
from the other backstories we've had so
far which actually now brings us to some
of the most important backstories in all
of Demon Slayer starting with obana
igoro who has maybe maybe the most
tragic backstory in the entire story
which I mean if you've been watching
this video throughout so far you will
know means a lot basically he was born
to a clan of Thieves who worshiped a
snake demon however this clan almost
never had male children so the snake
demon took a very special interest in
him they even kept him locked up in a
cage for most of his childhood and the
snake demon would then just watch him
late at night which I mean yikes super
creepy let's not think about it too much
and years later when he was at 12 years
old he was let out of the cage for the
very first time and he was immediately
brought to the snake demon and this was
very very bad for obanai because the
snake ordered that his mouth be cut open
kind of like the Joker so that it
matched the snakes which
and after this overnight was of course
understandably desperate to escape and
really his only happiness came from this
little snake buddy who he became close
friends with and when the snake demon
found out she was of course Furious and
killed nearly his entire family before
trying to recapture obanadi fortunately
though he was then actually saved by the
former flame hashira shinjuru rengoku
which led obanite to join the demon
Slayers because of his deep hatred for
the demons interestingly he also had a
deep fear and hatred of women since his
whole family that Captain locked up were
women although it is implied that he
actually fell in love with mitsuri and
it turns out that she loved him as well
so at least he got some small Joy before
they then both died no happy ends which
brings us to another demon hater
although this one is a demon himself
which is Tamayo who is the demon
researching a cure to turn nizuko back
into a human and interestingly enough
her backstory began over 500 years ago
that's because when she was 19 she fell
ill and was desperate for a cure she
then met muzan who said he could cure
her but he actually just turned her into
a demon instead which I mean muzan is
always best man but after her
transformation she mindlessly killed her
husband and children which did leave her
incredibly sad understandably that at
some point she even tried to kill muzan
but she failed and this basically broke
her spirit as a result she gave up and
basically ended up serving muzan until
she broke free from his control after
the fight with yorichi then from this
point on she stopped killing people and
eventually was able to live only by
drinking blood even though it pained her
not to eat people and then over the next
200 years she researched and learned
enough about medicine and science to
modify her body to not need to eat
humans anymore at all which of course
now brings us to the biggest demon and
not a weird person at all muzan and his
backstory tells us exactly how demons
actually came to exist that's because
over 1 000 years ago muzan was a sick
human who nearly died in his mother's
womb he was actually going to be
cremated because his family thought that
he was dead but they only took him out
of the fire when he finally cried out
loud no life did not get much better
because his weak body kept getting worse
at some point he started a very
experimental treatment from this very
random doctor but muzan was so
frustrated that it wasn't working that
he actually eventually killed the doctor
and only then did he realize that the
medicine was actually making him
stronger though in the end it actually
just ended up turning him into the very
first demon which I guess kind of mean
that they don't give us a backstory on
the doctor but from this time on he
started eating humans and grew stronger
with his main goal being to overcome his
weakness to the Sun and he tried to do
this in two ways first by finding the
blue spider lily flower which was part
of the medicine that he took which he
was never able to accomplish and the
second way was to constantly make demons
so that one day a demon might have the
power to to resist the Sun but maybe the
most unexpected thing about muzan was
that during his early years as a demon
he actually settled down with a woman
five times however in the end each of
these relationships ended with his wife
committing suicide because he was a very
abusive husband which we did not see
coming throughout this video at all
which definitely makes him the worst of
the worst demon and deadbeat husbands
the horror combo and then over the
centuries he created the upper and lower
Moons by forcefully turning strong
people into demons however one strong
fighter who chose to die instead of
becoming a demon was of course the flame
hasida kyoguro rengoku his life ended
after saving tanjiro and the others
during the Mugen train Arc and while I
already told you about his mom dying
another fact from his past that you
might not know is that during his first
mission as a Demon Slayer he actually
ruptured his own eardrums to overcome a
flute Demon's special abilities like
saying talk about dedication to killing
demons I guess which is of course why he
chose to die instead of becoming a demon
himself but I've actually always
wondered what might have happened if he
had actually chosen to live instead like
would he have become a good Demon or
might he even have had the potential to
become the strongest demon ever well you
can learn the answer to all of these
questions by watching this video right
here thanks for watching and I'll see
you in the next one